we were right
till we weren't
built a home and watched it burn Miley
Cyrus seems to have a message for her
ex-husband Liam Hemsworth in her new
song flowers she insists well she can
buy her own
[Music]
oh and did we mention Miley dropped the
track on January 13th Liam's birthday I
knew what feels true to you and like
what you want to do and I think your win
the video starts with Miley looking
stunning as she dances through the
streets in a gold Glam Ensemble that's
when she references the Malibu home she
shared with Liam which was destroyed in
a 2018 wildfire
[Music]
kind of dream that can't be sold
we were right till we weren't built a
home and watched it burn in my lease
2020 interview with Howard Stern she
revealed her marriage to Liam was
hanging on by a thread I just clung to
what I had left of that house which was
me and him and I really do and did love
him very very very much and still do
always well the wrecking ball singer
also added that there was too much
conflict and said quote I don't get off
on drama or fighting which she also
hints at on flowers
[Music]
I didn't want me
I didn't wanna fight started to cry but
then remembered
[Music]
artists were sensitive people we go
through a lot oh and there's also the
timing of the song's release on Liam's
33rd birthday Miley dropped it Thursday
night which was already January 13th in
Australia where the actor lives
is
[Music]
Glory more
no regret
I forgive every word you say
Miley and Liam dated on and off for 10
years after meeting on the set of the
last song in 2010. so what are you doing
down here my mom shipped me and my
brother to my dad's for the summer
guess if I could babysit turtle eggs
while a volleyball player slash aquarium
volunteer hits him every five seconds
so I mean we're shooting on the beach
every day it was you know pretty fun the
two got engaged in 2012 but ultimately
split but by 2016 Miley's engagement
ring was back on her finger maybe it
never goes exactly how I think it's
going to but somehow it always ends up
being better the pair then tied the knot
in a secret Tennessee wedding on
December 23 2018. it's the best it's the
best it's um you know I feel so lucky to
be with someone like her and yeah it's
great very very very lucky but fast
forward to August 2019 and Miley and
Liam announced their separation just
Days Later Liam filed for divorce and it
was finalized in January 2020. I just
find it's easier to not talk about my
personal life because usually I say the
wrong thing so it ends up just
complicating things more yeah but now
Miley's talk talking about it through
song and hinting she's better off
without that past lover
[Music]
s